somewhere deep in bear country lives the
berenstain bears family the Berenstain
small bit of news just in parallel
universes exists and we're living in a
different one than we did in our
childhoods I don't know if you guys
heard but apparently at some point in
the last decade or so a large number of
us got shifted to a parallel universe
and the Berenstein bears prove that I'm
gay poe writer and do parallel universes
exist sure but are some of us actually
from a parallel universe and somehow got
shifted into this one that's a much
bigger question let's find out this is
hashtag is now we all remember the
loveable Berenstein bears of our youth
that furry nuclear family with wholesome
all-american names like papa mama
sister brother very creative but if
their other name that's causing all this
controversy apparently everyone
remembers that it spelled Berenstein a
ein but according to the publisher and
writers it's never been spelled that way
it's always been Berenstain AI n take a
moment and rack your own memory do you
spell a TI n if so you're like most
people if you spell it
AI n then you're clearly part of the
cover-up now some people have noticed
this strange phenomenon before but
rapper producer and admitted pothead LP
stumbled across this crazy idea and
brought it back into life the Berenstein
bear theory as it's known posits that at
some point in the last 10 years our
universe crossed over with an alternate
parallel universe where the bear family
name is known as stain not steen now
it's not just low-level rappers that are
pushing this idea a graduate student of
physics put some elbow grease into
really tried to show that reality has
been tampered with and history has been
retro actively changed he claims that
somehow our universe rotated by PI over
2 kind of like 90 degrees and while most
things line up just some things are
different
like the spelling of these beloved bears
last names now as for me personally I do
remember it being very enstein I mean it
just makes sense there are so many
famous teens Einstein Frankenstein or
else D that's not how you say those ok
nice try but I can only handle one
conspiracy there at a time please so
that's not their last name then what is
real if you go do your homework look at
the pictures the book covers they all
show the name as Berenstain with an A
and the TV show confirms this the
Berenstain
though her accent doesn't help clear any
of this up but there is some evidence of
a possible Berenstein past and
subsequent cover-up a reddit user claims
to have pictures of lots of evidence but
for some reason his post event
mysteriously deleted another piece of
evidence a TV Guide from the 1980s and a
few other instances of the ein spell now
while some may say that the reddit user
is lying the pictures are photoshopped
and that the other stuff could just
simply be typos I think that they're
probably right and if they really were
rewriting Berenstein history I think
they probably would have gone back and
erased this blatantly racist book where
Papa Bear hates Pandits look at his face
he's so mad that they're different so
why are we even talking about this
simply put huge amounts of people
clearly remember it as steam so how can
this happen it's called the Mandela
effect where a large group of people
have vivid memories of a specific event
even if that event isn't historically
accurate it's named for a similar
phenomenon where in the 80s a lot of
people remembered that South African
activist Nelson Mandela died in prison
but as we know from history this didn't
actually happen
Mandela eventually gained his freedom
was a very prominent social justice
figure and grew old enough to look so
much like Morgan Freeman right I mean
that's pretty uncanny they could be
brothers or the same person this could
be another parallel universe
intertwining we're gonna get to the
bottom of this and you know the portrait
of King Henry the eighth's and royal
regalia holding up a big turkey leg
people have even parodied the portrait
since then and referenced it regularly
when talking about King Henry the
eighth's but that portrait does not
exist everyone who thinks so has been
duped by Morgan Freeman the magician of
the parallel universes some people swear
that New Zealand is located north of
Australia when really it's South East
just looking at a map would solve that
problem so is this proof that parallel
universes exists and we just hop between
them no some people just have bad
memories the universe isn't crashing or
exploding or dying actually okay well
still it probably is Berenstain and we
just have been saying it wrong forever
it's like the word niche neat thank you
it's impossible to find a consensus so
let's just let people say it either way
and pretend like it's all the same oh
except if they say Bernstein that's
never right shame those people okay well
hopefully that helped you figure out
this is something but I'm not a total
killjoy okay if you want to see other
times that the universe is brain farted
you can see all kinds of weird little
happen stances on the subreddit glitch
in the matrix or Vendela effect let us
know in the comments what your favorite
universe glitches are and if you think
it's Berenstain or Berenstein and
for more universe stuff whether it's
parallel dyeing or marvel cinematic we
do a lot of Marvel stuff here
I'm Gabe Hill writer and now that that's
all answered I've got a question that
I've always wanted to answer what's mama
bear gonna look like when she gets out
of the PJs and into some nightlife
attire I mean oh I mean oh she's a bear